formerly we'll be using its cosine theta
equals u dot V so that's the dot product
of two vectors divided by the magnitude
of U times the magnitude of V so the
magnitude just means the length of the
vector and the way you do that is you
can I'll just show you for example so
say your vector is like this to find
that length you're just doing the
Pythagorean theorem so it's the
x-coordinate squared plus the
y-coordinates squared and then you take
the square root so if you like square
root of x squared plus y squared so
that'll give you the magnitude of the
vector now to find the angle we'll have
to end up taking the cosine inverse to
get the theta by itself so in our
example here we're looking at vector U
which is 3/4 we're going right three up
four so if you do the Pythagorean
theorem you're gonna find out this has a
magnitude of five this vector here
vector V is five negative 12 so we're
going write five down 12 and then if we
do the Pythagorean theorem for that one
this is going to have a magnitude of 13
okay so I'll just circle those and we
want to find the angle between the two
vectors so first step we want to dot the
two vectors so we're going to multiply
the x coordinates 3 times 5 which is 15
plus we're gonna multiply the Y
coordinates that's going to be negative
48 divided by the magnitude of U which
is 5 times the magnitude of V which is
13 okay and this equals the cosine of
theta ok so if we simplify that down we
get negative 33 divided by 65 but then
what we're going to do is to find theta
we're going to take the cosine inverse
of negative 30 360 fifths